Speaker 1: OK, let's now talk about what's
going on with what could maybe be and could
have been a real commission to investigate
what happened on the day of the Trump riots,
January 6th.
Twenty twenty one.
There's a new piece in Huff Post, very interesting
piece by Jennifer Bendery called the one hundred
thirty nine Republicans who lied, fueled an
insurrection and then voted to cover it up.
She writes, Last week, thirty five Senate
Republicans killed a bipartisan effort to
create an independent commission to investigate
the January 6th insurrection at the US Capitol,
arguably the greatest attack on American democracy
since the Civil War.
It would indeed have been bipartisan.
Remember that?
That's really important.
Some Republicans are saying it would have
been a partizan witch hunt.
It was going to be 10 members of the House,
five Democrats, five Republicans, five chosen
by Democrats, five chosen by Republicans.
The chair of the commission would have been
a Democrat and the vice chair would have been
a Republican because Democrats control the
House, after all, and all subpoenas issued
would have had to be signed off on by both
the Democratic chair and the Republican vice
chair.
It was going to be the closest you could have
to a truly bipartisan commission.
Many Republicans saying it was going to be
a partizan witch hunt.
She goes on to write a week earlier, one hundred
and thirty one hundred and seventy five House
Republicans opposed creating the commission
to why would any U.S. senator or member of
Congress oppose an independent commission
to investigate what led to a deadly attack
on the US Capitol, one aimed squarely at undermining
American democracy and the peaceful transfer
of power?
The reasons are as cynical as they are obvious,
and this is the exact analysis we gave last
week.
Most of these Republicans lied about the presidential
election being stolen from Donald Trump.
That lie helped motivate a white supremacist
mob of Trump supporters to smash their way
into the Capitol, some with plans to kill
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi, Vice President
Mike Pence and others to stop Congress from
certifying Joe Biden's electoral win.
Republicans don't want a respected panel of
experts publicly connecting the dots heading
into the twenty twenty two elections.
This is an additional part that's interesting.
They also don't want to get on Trump's bad
side by supporting a commission that would
show in detail how his lie incited an attack
on democracy that left five people dead, hundreds
of police officers injured and countless others
traumatized.
There are two things going on here.
Republicans know these Republicans, the ones
that were doing the inciting and that voted
against these Republicans know if the investigation
is done properly, they will probably be in
the spotlight as part of the problem.
The people doing the commission, some of the
people doing the commission will really be
culpable themselves of what the commission
is investigating.
That's part one.
Part two.
We're going to talk about this later.
There is every indication that, yes, not only
is Donald Trump interested in running in twenty,
twenty four, it's probably his nomination
to take or decline.
In other words, there is every indication
that many or most Republicans still believe
and why wouldn't they?
It's borne out in the polls.
Republicans still accurately believe that
Trump is the head of the party.
Trump will play kingmaker in twenty twenty
two.
Trump is about to restart rallies.
Trump is still pushing these audits and Trump
is likely to try to run in twenty four if
a health issue keeps him out of it.
As many of you write to me and say, OK, but
that is likely the reality.
And so why would you get on Trump's bad side
by voting in favor of this?
Because Trump holds grudges and Trump is vindictive.
And he will remember one more piece from this
article.
Jennifer Bendery writes, It gets uglier.
Their party is counting on people to keep
believing the lie.
Republican led state legislatures all over
the country are using the lie to justify quickly
passing bills to significantly restrict voting
in ways that would disproportionately hurt
communities of color.
Just this year, state lawmakers have already
issued at least three hundred and eighty nine
restrictive bills in forty nine states and
passed 22 restrictive laws in 14 states.
It's no coincidence that the four states where
Republicans have filed the most bills aimed
at restricting voting Georgia, Arizona, Michigan
and Pennsylvania, where some of the closest
states in the 2012 presidential election as
538 notes, all four of those states went for
Biden and have Republican controlled legislatures,
which makes them especially ripe for new voting
restrictions.
So three reasons here, really, why you are
seeing this Republican opposition.
One, the commission would likely find that
they were part of the problem, too.
They want to stay in Donald Trump's good graces
because it seems Trump is going to have power
and control in the Republican Party for a
long period of time to come, at least through
the twenty, twenty two election.
If he fails to pick the winners in 2022, things
may change, but at least through 2022.
And number three, if they can continue putting
off a real investigation into what happened,
which would, of course, uncover that the election
was fine, the election wasn't rigged, Joe
Biden just won.
They lose the ability if that is made public
through the commission to keep justifying.
These further restrictions on voting that
they're passing in many states, so Democrats
need to move forward with a probe without
any Republicans.
There's a couple of ways that it could happen.
It would then actually be a bipartisan commission.
Now, I know what you might be thinking.
You know, David, Republicans falsely say we
don't want to participate in this because
it's going to be partizan.
And then as a result, Democrats just move
forward and it is partizan.
That is that that is, of course, what they
are going to claim.
But the benefits of doing the commission by
far outweigh claims from Republicans that
it's partizan because they were going to make
those claims anyway.
And we do need to see Democrats do something.
The headlines continue coming that Democrats
aren't holding them accountable.
And to a degree, it's true.
Now, so far, they've been trying to just get
the votes to do it with Republicans.
It's not clear that that's going to happen.
They've got to figure out a move for a way
to move forward on their own.
It'll be called partizan either way.
So I'd rather the commission be done in some
way, shape or form than not.
Let me know what you think.
And we're going to have more on this on The
David Pakman Show Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show.
Check it out and we'll be back right after
this.